last week I did a segment
for our Tick Tock account which by the
way Tick Tock over 500 000 followers on
Tick Tock it's crazy what's going on
we're reaching young people we're wild
things are happening on Tick Tock I did
a segment where I laid out why I don't
think the impact of Trump's arrest will
be limited only to the presidential race
and the point I made was that there's
going to be a significant trickle-down
effect now I'm wondering whether I did
this for tick tock or for our straight
arrow news partnership but in any case I
do remember talking about this maybe
even on the bonus show now I don't
remember
my argument is as follows it would be
wrong to assume that Trump's trials and
indictments will only affect the
presidential race I believe that it will
affect down ballot Republicans and it
has the potential depending on how this
all goes over the next six to 18 months
to generate an insane amount of chaos
for Republicans trying to get themselves
reelected in November of 2024. if you
are a pro-trump Acolyte and you're
trying to get reelected and Trump really
has legal issues and is damaged in the
primary maybe loses it or wins but then
loses to Joe Biden
it could turn off a lot of people from
voting for their local elected official
house or senate for re-election on the
other hand if you take the anti-trump
side as a republican seeking re-election
in 2024 and Trump prevails that could
end up being very damaging to you so
there's a lot of risk here to many in
the Republican party and as we talked
about late last week Republicans are
worried that Trump is going to drag them
down we now are really starting to look
at trial calendars and Republican debate
schedules and primary schedules and it
is hard to Come Away with any conclusion
other than the one that Newsweek has
come across or come come uh to believe
which is that as they say Donald Trump
is likely to be swamped with multiple
overlapping criminal trials
this is the one scenario other than a
health problem that could derail Donald
Trump's campaign Newsweek writes Donald
Trump is at risk of being faced with
multiple criminal trials at the same
time all while campaigning to become
president in 2024. Tuesday Trump pleaded
not guilty to 37 Federal offenses
connected to the Jack Smith documents
case and is expected to appear next in
Florida Court in June
um it is currently unknown when a trial
could be set for the classified
documents case with the decision to be
made by judge Eileen Cannon of course as
we talked about appointed to the bench
by Trump facing calls to recuse herself
uh the article continues the New York
trial will will take place this is the
other trial the New York trial will take
place while the Republican primary is
well underway and after the so-called
super Tuesday were several States vote
on the same day
elsewhere there have been indications
that the criminal investigation in
Georgia
is drawing to a close and Trump could
face former indictments that's going to
be
um sometime between July and September
probably here they're talking about July
and August Etc afani Willis's office
says federal indictments will not have
any impact on the Fulton County election
investigation saying what she is doing
is going to happen regardless of what is
happening federally and then it's also
important to remember
that Donald Trump is
um potentially going to be federally
indictment indicted an additional time
related to January 6th so when we think
about what could derail Trump a health
problem but that could happen to anybody
anybody could be derailed by a health
problem the political scenario that
could derail Trump is that he is so
flooded with criminal trials that he
quite literally just can't keep
campaigning it pulls him off the
campaign Trail Trump has pledged to stay
in regardless that is his pledge but
Trump says things all the time that end
up not being true this is really a
cautionary Tale it's best to commit only
one crime per year so that you can keep
your schedule clear I'm sort of kidding
of course Trump is innocent until proven
guilty I still doubt at the end of the
day
that the path away from Trump in this
primary is that he drops out uh I
believe or that the path out of trump in
this election is that he drops out I see
it as far more likely that Trump stays
in wins the primary but loses to Joe
Biden in 2024 I believe that is the most
likely scenario the second most likely
scenario is Trump stays in the primary
but loses the primary less likely but
still possible and I believe the least
likely scenario uh is that Donald Trump
bails on the primary and even less
likely I think it's Trump dies and is no
longer a candidate I would put that as
for that's my order for this at the end
of the day
it really is up to Republicans to decide
what it is that they want and right now
although the polling is moving a little
bit and we're I know we're going to look
at polling later this week
the polling is moving a little bit but
Trump is still very much in control
Chris Christie's argument is when you
talk to the Trump supporters today
about half of them or more say I do
support Trump as of today but I'm open
to supporting somebody else Chris
Christie's argument is if you take the
people who are definitely not supporting
Trump in the primary and then you add to
that the number of people supporting
Trump but willing to vote for someone
else that's enough to win and Chris
Christie is correct mathematically the
question is what would it take for that
group that says I support Trump but I'm
willing to look elsewhere what would it
take to get them to actually look
elsewhere and even two more indictments
I don't believe is going to change their
mind